did you ever do the trick
i forget what they call it but when you
when you uh
instruct the crowd to to to
split into two groups like down the
middle and then they all run at each
other
oh that wallet test thing yeah i
really we don't do that yeah that's
always been like the blacks that's so
straight like thrash cool thing it's
cool at metal shows and
it's amazing to watch but i've never had
the crowds do that right i like watching
that [ __ ]
i think the first time i saw that was
that papa roach
like i forget if i was doing a show with
papa roach but i just remember
like you know jacoby the the singer
paparazzi she's like
all right everybody's split up and then
on the count of three run into each
other and i'm thinking dude you can't do
that that's like a lawsuit yeah
that's like brave hard [ __ ] it's a real
big glass suit
it's so badass to see it though i've
watched it at festivals
in europe you know those humongous
crowds and you just see them just
bam and you just know someone's getting
jacked up yeah
yeah dude